today on the matt wall show espn has an
on-air moment of silence to protest the
florida parental rights bill meanwhile
backlash against the ncaa's policies
allowing men in women's sports continues
to grow with no sign of abating is the
cultural tide turning we'll talk about
that also ukrainian president zielinski
invokes the holocaust while appealing
for more countries to get involved in
the war in ukraine is that comparison
fair plus the white house considers
stimulus checks and gas cards to solve
the gas prices problem which will do
wonders for the inflation problem of
course and the media twists itself into
knots trying to debunk the claim that
biden's scotus nominee has a tendency to
be lenient on child sex predators but
their debunking only succeeds in proving
the claim that was originally made we'll
talk about all that and more today on
the matt wall show
[Music]
well interest rates continue to
fluctuate they're volatile and i really
can't stress this enough it's important
to get ahead of them and lock into a
lower rate while you can look there are
still five million homeowners who can
benefit by saving hundreds maybe up to a
thousand dollars a month you've just got
to call american financing america's
home for home loans where you'll get a
free mortgage review from a salary-based
consultant there's no pressure no
obligation there's no upfront or hidden
fees it's very simple right to the point
just a simple conversation around custom
loans that may fit your budget better
from lower rates to shorter terms and
even debt consolidation it really could
mean up to a thousand dollars in monthly
savings plus tens of thousands long term
and if you start soon you could close in
as fast as 10 days like with all the
inflation and uh and and
many people in this country hurting
economically you got to look for all the
savings that you can find and here's one
place to start just with a phone call
and all you do is call 866-569-4711
that's
866-569-4711 or visit
americanfinancing.net
nmls18234 and mlsconsumeraccess.org
now these people are of course incapable
of shame and so um all of the
embarrassment was felt secondhand on
friday when espn paused during its
coverage of the women's ncaa basketball
tournament to have a moment of silence
in protests of the florida legislation
which lying opponents have dishonestly
dubbed the don't say gay bill the stun
sparked for one thing
a philosophical debate among some people
which is that you know if espn anchors
stage a protest during women's
basketball coverage and nobody is
watching to notice did it really happen
we'll leave that discussion for another
time for now here is one anchor
explaining the demonstration watch
legislation happening in florida and
across other states as well that are
targeting our lgbtqi plus communities
many of our colleagues here at espn have
planned and organized a walkout that
will be happening at 3 pm eastern today
and to be honest with you we thought we
were going to come here today and really
celebrate a sport that has meant so much
and done so much including for so many
in the lgbtqia plus communities but we
understand the gravity of this
legislation and also how it is affecting
so many families across this country and
because of that our ally ship is going
to take a front seat and with that we're
going to pause in solidarity
wow
i mean
i can't decide what's more brave the
blatant lies the phrase our ally ship
will take a front seat or the moment of
silence on a broadcast with zero viewers
it's hard to say but she wasn't alone
the announcers on the court also joined
in let's listen to that
our
lgbtqia plus teammates at disney asked
for our solidarity and support including
our company's support in opposition to
the parental rights in education bill in
the state of florida and similar
legislation across the united states and
a threat to any
human rights is a threat to all human
rights and at this time courtney and i
we're going to take a pause from our
broadcast to show our love and support
for our friends our families and our
colleagues
[Music]
needless to say of course none of these
people have read the bill or know what's
in it or have any idea what's going on
now you don't actually see the whole
moment of silence there but trust me
it's uh it it was inspirational
speaking of inspiring disney on the same
day announced that in further protests
of the florida legislation that forbids
teachers from talking to six-year-olds
about their sexuality that's the thing
that's a threat to human rights is if we
don't allow teachers to talk to
six-year-olds about their sexuality then
human rights are threatened because what
because six-year-olds have a human right
to be sexually indoctrinated by their
creepy pervert teachers or is it that
the creepy person for teachers have a
human right to indoctrinate kids yeah i
think that's probably what it is as far
as they're concerned but anyway disney
announced that they would be releasing a
film um where two lesbian cartoon
characters make out
and this again is is you know another
inspiring thing that they're doing uh
because of the bill this from the daily
wire says pixar has reportedly decided
to reinstate a same-sex kiss in the
upcoming animated children's film light
year in response to florida's so-called
don't say gay bill and the walt disney
company's leadership responds to it a
source close to the production said the
next feature film from the studio about
the real-life story of how the famed toy
story character buzz lightyear came to
be
will reportedly include a kiss between
two female characters reported variety
in a piece published friday one of the
characters is reportedly a significant
female role by the name of hawthorne
um
so by the way this is i mean just to
clarify this is a cartoon
about the origin story
of the film character
that the buzz lightyear toy
is based on
that's the the origin story
a fake origin story
of a fake character from a fake movie
that a fake toy
was was based on if you're wondering
whether major hollywood studios are
utterly and completely out of ideas
i think i should probably answer it for
you
i mean no self-respect in person should
have ever even been considering buying
tickets for this 100 minute toy
commercial to begin with but especially
not now
now that it's being used not only as a
vehicle to sell disney merchandise which
is the main reason why any disney movie
exists but also as a forum to protest
the prohibition of childhood
sexualization
and yet we see in this move by disney
and the demonstrations on espn and all
the other theatrics from the left
surrounding this bill
a certain not so subtle hint of
desperation
because they're panicked frenzied
they can see the cultural tide turning
slightly and they're terrified
speaking of which the leah thomas
charade at the ncaa women's swimming
championships last week has become its
own sort of watershed moment no pun
intended there's a backlash against the
trans agenda right now unlike anything
we've seen to this point in our culture
and it hasn't abated even after thomas
lost his final races over the weekend
clearly throwing the competition
intentionally so the gender ideologues
could point to it and say see it's not
so unfair after all i mean he he won
handily in this was a 500 meter race and
then uh the couple races he did on
saturday he he lost he came in sixth
place or something
um wasn't even competitive so pretty
clear that he lost on purpose
but that has done little to stem the
tide of outrage nor should it on sunday
an ncaa swimmer by the name of rika
giorgi
wrote a letter to the ncaa protesting
their decision to let a male compete now
she's the first female swimmer to
formally and publicly complain with her
name attached
bold move brave move necessary move
and i admire her for it
now on the other hand i
you know i don't think it's splitting
hairs to point out that when i read this
letter
um
she refers to leah thomas as she
multiple times
and also talks about how much she
respects leah thomas and all those
things and leah thomas is pursuing his
dreams or rather her dreams
and so on and so forth now this doesn't
totally negate the impact of the letter
but um it does diminish it slightly
sadly because by calling thomas she
it concedes the underlying claim that
thomas is making i mean either thomas is
a she
or not and he's not
and since he's not he doesn't belong in
the women's league
but if he was a she then there'd be no
reason to complain
and trying to keep him out or her out in
that case
would indeed be unfair and wrong
i mean literally the only argument
against thomas's participation and it's
the only argument we need
is that he is a he that's the whole
argument there is nothing else that's
all there is to say he's a he
by calling he she you undercut yourself
accidentally conceding the very point
you're supposed to be arguing against
so the letter is a good start um
definitely again i don't mean to detract
from the bravery it took to write it and
it does take bravery
but
we need to go a lot farther
i mean this was this is this is this is
a a good start a good step
we need to go farther than that
and we need to be arguing against
all of this on a on a fundamental level
so here was another good sign the
swimming finals was also the scene of a
confrontation between activist kelly j
keane
and a man who now identifies as a trans
woman after 50 years as a man
um keane was trying to explain to this
guy why she is not comfortable with him
using the female restroom and here's how
that exchange went
hang on on the basis of the comfort and
dignity of girls and women i'm asking
you and telling you please do not lose
women's faces
uncomfortable my girls and the other
women i am with are very comfortable
with being right
i'm not your daughter and my daughter is
also not your daughter that's right and
she would still
she would feel very uncomfortable
right now
excuse me
do not use female faces
as a mother this is a 50 year old dude
who after 50 years as a dude decided to
put on a wig and call himself a woman i
mean that's it
one day he wakes up puts a wig on mama
i'm a mother having skipped all of the
most difficult aspects of motherhood he
now wants to claim the title for himself
except you ran into at least one woman
who won't go along with it doesn't want
the women's restroom to turn into a
masquerade ball or a costume party for
this guy's sake what comes across most
of all in the conversation between the
two
is as i pointed to many times the the
overwhelming suffocating narcissism of
the trans person in this exchange
um he simply doesn't care how anyone
else feels and
you know what anyone else wants
he takes whatever he wants for himself
without any concern for anybody around
him
he claims the bathrooms of women he
claims their very identities
tries to make it all his own somewhat
paradoxically though while he covets
womanhood
he also very clearly has incredible
contempt for the women themselves
he hates women
but yet wants to be them
and he along with all the all the other
gender ideologues have been running
roughshod over the culture for years
taking whatever they want with no
resistance
that finally seems to be changing
slightly
now don't get me wrong i'm not declaring
victory we're a very long way off from
anything that can be considered a
cultural victory on this front or any
other front because victory if it comes
is years down the line generations away
probably it took generations to lose the
culture will take generations to get it
back
but recently we have seen some movement
in the right direction
we're seeing some of that here
baby steps towards sanity and moral
decency
now these advances could easily stall if
we succeed in say getting men out of
women's sports and then decide that
that's good enough call ourselves the
winner go back to ignoring the issue i
can see that happening
or if we all you know
go with the line that some conservatives
have adopted claiming that you know we
have no problem with the left's gender
theories in general we just care about
fairness and sports or privacy in the
bathroom
or whatever as if that's the fundamental
issue which it isn't
what we have to remain firm on
is that we are we have a problem with
the very concept you know the very con
the guy there in the wig the very
concept
that he could be a woman because he says
he is that's that is what we are taking
issue with that's what we're arguing
against
that's what we're fighting
it's not just this or that particular
thing that that guy wants to do
but it's the very claim that he is
making about himself
there are still a lot of people on the
right who are
very cautious about that very afraid
and so you see this even now you see you
see plenty of people
you know even conservatives who who for
the first time are really speaking out
about some of this stuff they're saying
oh i don't have any problem with
transgenderism it's just it's just
women's sports that i care about
now we adopt that we make that our line
that's a mistake and we lose
meanwhile
you know the left will only become more
desperate more enraged
try to push even further
as we're seeing down in florida they
will they will double down and triple
down then double down on their triple
down again as they've done in florida
the battle only gets more vicious from
here but i think we're finally moving
ever so slightly
in the right direction
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
we're talking about all the inflation
the one area where we see inflation more
than ever is in the grocery store even
the grocery prices feel like they've
doubled good ranchers though
for them prices have stayed low and
affordable
i know you're you're used to the
heartburn that you get when you go to
buy food and you see how much more
expensive it is even from the last time
that you went well you can get rid of
that heartburn by just shopping good
ranchers instead because once you
subscribe your price never goes up your
best price is locked in for life shop
good ranches for all your beef chicken
and seafood needs good ranchers only
sells 100 american meat from local farms
and ranches they have signature steak
burgers that are packed full of flavor
their pre-trimmed and pre-marinated
chicken breasts which we had for dinner
just last night by the way are
absolutely delicious and so easy to
prepare plus their packaging makes it
easy to cook what you want and save the
rest which keeps you from wasting
anything their animals are ethically
raised and sustainably sourced they do
things the right way and it shows in
every box and in every bite that you
take of their delicious food as well so
get your 30 discount on prime steaks and
better than organic chicken today go to
goodranchers.com walsh to save on the
quality you've been looking for good
ranchers takes the guesswork out of the
grocery store by sourcing everything
from local farms and shipping it to your
door so use my code wall should enjoy
your box of 100 american meat and your
30 savings order now to combat inflation
with good ranchers american meat
delivered well not one of my parenting
highlights necessarily um not an
award-winning moment for me but
yesterday my two-year-old daughter
emma was um
running through the house calling her
brother a coward she was running after
him saying come here you coward shouting
at him
and i'm like wait how is she saying
coward where did she learn that word and
how does she know the correct context to
use it
and that's what my older son reminded me
that she learned it from me
because i called her my two-year-old a
coward a few days ago which i had
forgotten about
which i did it's true now that he
mentions it but you have to understand
the context here okay we were playing
with lightsabers and um
emma kept claiming that she wanted to
fight me with the lightsaber she would
grab a lightsaber they fight me daddy
and then so then i would square up you
know to have the lights and then she
would run behind the couch she would run
away
and so i was saying to her come out you
coward and face me like a man
and she took that to heart uh too much
and now i'm gonna really seem like a
freak even more than usual when my
daughter says it in public and some
stranger asks where she heard that word
and my older kids will be very excited
to say oh she heard it from daddy when
daddy called her a coward
so that's what's going to happen but on
the other hand i guess there is
something kind of perfect about me
having a toddler who talks to people
that way because it's sort of exactly
what you would expect i guess very on
brand
um okay i want to start with this right
at the top of the uh five headlines the
five-ish headlines
last week dave rubin who um i'm sure you
all
know announced that he was going to be
having two children via surrogacy
um
now unlike most of the other hosts here
at the daily wire
i don't know reuben personally
i've never met him
um i do know his work and i appreciate
it i agree with many of his opinions
that i've heard him express over over
recent years
based on his work and what he said you
know i know that well obviously he's gay
and until recently he identified as an
atheist i don't think he does anymore
but i'm not sure about that i'm not not
a very religious man as far as i know
and also as far as i know at no point
has he called himself a conservative if
i had to pick a label for him i would
say seems to me he's more of a
libertarian in fairness i don't know if
that's the label he picks for himself
um
all that to say
this news out of reuben's personal life
didn't come as a particular surprise to
me
i also didn't hear the news until late
last week thursday or friday and i heard
about it only because some people on the
right started trolling my comments on
twitter and i guess on youtube also
demanding that i denounce dave rubin and
accusing me of cowardice because i
hadn't yet
um
and quickly these people i guess had
just sort of decided that i'm some sort
of culture war squish who supports gay
marriage because i hadn't said anything
about dave rubin
one of the guys leading this charge
against me and other conservatives who
hadn't said anything publicly to that
point um was mark dice who's a
conservative commentator and youtuber
whose videos you've probably seen in the
past
all this was exacerbated by the fact
that certain other prominent
conservatives
and other conservative outlets such as
the blaze for example had publicly
congratulated ruben for the news about
the surrogacy and the kids
now this i think rightfully
perturbed
conservatives in the audience
some of whom very unrightfully decided
all at once that that i was part of this
and i had tacitly congratulated dave by
not saying anything
this all came to a head on sunday when i
finally got into a back and forth with
mark dice got kind of heated as far as
that goes
you know i talked to mark privately
we've
put it behind us you know honestly i'm
i'm not looking to have any feuds with
people on the right i've done that in
the past i told him when we talked about
it privately i said i've had
i've gotten into fights with people on
the right in the past and at the end i
always feel like the only winner was the
left and so i just don't want to do that
and so that's all that needs to be said
about that as for the dave rubin
situation specifically
you know my views on gay marriage and
surrogacy in all related matters are
very clear and have been extremely
consistent for many many years
i've never wavered on any of these
issues ever in my life and i never would
reuben obviously is not an exception to
that
and
i honestly don't think he would expect
me
to see him as an exception in fact i'm
quite sure of that because he's spoken
about this before by the fact that he's
got a conservative audience and he's he
kind of has a lot of conservative
friends
uh many of whom don't agree with
with uh with many of these things
and you know he's aware of that
and he's okay with it
i also have no problem saying any of
this but when people come at me with
accusations
making demands
telling me that i have to say this or
that i'm not going to cooperate that's
not how i do things it's not how i
operate
when you come at me and say i demand
that you say whatever i'm not going to
say it because that's i just i don't
respond to that
um
but for the people who maybe are
unfamiliar with my work or you know and
are looking around now at all the
conservatives who seem to now be
endorsing
gay surrogacy something that something
that would have been totally unthinkable
10 years ago
i mean 10 years ago it's unthinkable
that you would have anyone who
identifies as conservative endorsing
you know gay surrogacy even people on
the left most most of them 10 years ago
or at least 15 years ago would not have
and so there are people you know people
may be looking around at that and aren't
as familiar with me and maybe are
sincerely wondering where i stand on it
um i will
speak to that and obviously it has
nothing to do with with harboring any
ill will towards dave who i think does
really good work and by all accounts is
a good guy just comes down to this three
things really
um
one when it comes to marriage
i believe that marriage is a particular
thing
with a particular function and purpose
um it's meant to be the foundation of
the nuclear family and as such it's the
foundation of human society
the relationship between man and woman
is special and unique because it has the
capacity in principle to produce human
life
no other relationship
among humans has that ability
and so the man and woman relationship is
a different sort of thing
and ought to have a different name and
be cherished and protected in a way that
other relationships are not you know the
way that i've i've when i've talked
about this on college campuses as i've
as i have many times
the way that i've tried to you know sort
of
explain it is just imagine if if human
society
um
collapsed and everybody's
you know memories were erased and
you were rising out of the rubble and
looking around and you don't have no
memory of anything before this
and you look around and you see you know
different human relationships people
people pairing up in various different
ways and you notice that this one kind
of relationship has this funny habit of
making people you know if you saw that
you would probably think well
we should we should call that something
that's an important thing that we should
protect and that's a it's different it's
a different sort of thing from any of
these other relationships
um
and that's why marriage is
between a man and a woman that's that's
what it is that's what it's supposed to
be
is the context in which this
relationship occurs
it's also true of course that i'm a
christian and my faith calls me
um
to defend what we now call quote unquote
traditional marriage
but there's a reason
you know there's a reason why the bible
teaches what it does about marriage and
this is what i'm trying to articulate
second um i think that every child
deserves and needs a mother and a father
that's a foundational principle
one that we can't abandon
without seeing the whole edifice come
crashing down on itself
like that's that's a block you can't
really pull from the jenga tower without
the tower toppling over
uh if we're gonna talk about defending
the family then i think that's a
principle we have to defend that every
child deserves a mother and father
third i'm opposed to surrogacy no matter
who is doing it um gay or straight
because it's the commodification of the
female body i mean you're you're renting
a woman's womb to grow a baby often it
involves
buying a woman's egg eggs and then and
then another woman's womb
okay so that meaning you're making
commodities of both the female body and
human life
and i oppose that
so those are my views always have been
um like i said i don't i don't make
exceptions and i don't think dave would
want or expect to be an exception
because he strikes me as the kind of guy
who respects when people stand on their
principles even if he doesn't agree with
those principles
so
that's where i stand but it is an
important conversation
and i think it's something that we
should we should be clear about all
right let's go here this is from the
daily wire um
on sunday ukraine's president
zielinski sparked outrage when he
compared the russian invasion of ukraine
to the holocaust during a speech to the
israeli government
he said the russian invasion of ukraine
is not just a military operation as
moscow claims this is a large-scale and
treacherous war aimed at destroying our
people destroying our children our
families our state our cities our
communities our culture and everything
that makes ukrainians ukrainians
everything that russian troops are now
destroying deliberately in front of the
whole world this is why i have the right
to this parallel into this comparison
with the holocaust of world war ii our
history and your history our war for our
survival and world war ii
then he goes on from there
talk making comparisons to the nazis and
and uh and so on
you know
uh of course the
one of the ironies here is when uh when
zielenski invokes the nazis and the
holocaust it it is also true that there
is a there's a nazi faction
in ukraine an actual nazi faction in
ukraine
um
that even now some mainstream media
outlets are admitting to him originally
that was like a conspiracy theory not a
lot of talk about it but that that's an
actual thing
uh doesn't mean that
putin is right
it's just another detail in this
conflict that i think we all have a
right to know because
any time there's a war between two
nations it's all it's it's it's
never going to be as simple as you want
it to be and this one certainly isn't
uh meanwhile this from the guardian says
11 ukrainian political parties have been
suspended because of their links with
russia according to ukrainian president
zielinski the country's national
security and defense council took the
decision to ban the parties from any
political activity so he banned these
political parties then on sunday the
ukrainian leader signed a decree that
aims to unite all national tv channels
into one platform
i was abolishing all the tv channels and
just making one
citing the infra the importance of a
unified information policy
there's another detail
that i think we should know
especially when we're told the
warmongers in our country who want us to
get involved in this conflict risking
world war three they're more than
willing to do it the war mongers anyway
more than willing to risk a nuclear war
even
um and one of the reasons that they give
us is that um is that this is something
we need to do to defend democracy
well
this is what the ukrainian democracy
looks like
that's all this this is
my position all along with this
has been number one i just don't like
being lied to
um
just be be honest with us
i think i don't think that's too much to
ask for
but of course this entire time if you
simply ask for the truth
like what exactly is going on why are
these things happening that's all it's
simple questions
if you ask for that then you're a stooge
of putin all right let's go next year
this one daily wire says the uh the
white house is reportedly holding off on
the idea of sending gas cards prepaid
debit cards loaded with taxpayers money
that the government would send to
certain americans to use towards
gasoline after push back from democrats
who worried the idea would never work in
providing economic relief in the face of
high fuel prices
instead president joe biden's team and
the gang on capitol hill
are reportedly considering more stimulus
checks raising gas prices raising rather
raising gas taxes on oil companies
to fund means-based assistance and
rescinding federal oil leases to
companies who do not use them to tackle
the problem of high gasoline prices
uh an in-depth look at the proposed
plans alongside common sense would lead
one to believe the white house plan
serious otherwise would cause more
inflation and higher gas prices
um
on saturday axios reported that the
white house considered giving americans
gas cards but democrat caucus laid out
why it was a bad idea and here's why
this is why the democrat democrats
themselves didn't want the gas cards and
they said it would be expensive and
poorly targeted it could worsen
inflation
uh delivering the cards would be a slow
process that could bog down the irs in
the middle of the filing season
potentially delaying people's tax
returns
and um and then so they're looking at
other things so
and i agree with that when gas prices go
out just saying oh we'll send gas cards
to everybody or not even everybody to
certain people
that's that's not much of a solution i
agree with that but then how is the
solution to send stimulus checks instead
talk about poorly targeted
this has been the problem with these
stimulus checks all along going back to
covid
just start sending checks to everybody
but make making not even any effort to
figure out who actually yeah before we
even talk about whether it's a good idea
in general to just send the just send
the the free money out to people but no
effort is even being made to figure out
who actually needs it who doesn't just
send it to everybody or you know set an
arbitrary income limit and everybody
underneath that that income is going to
get it
and you're going back into cova like
even if you didn't if you if you earned
under a certain amount even if you
didn't lose your job but you're doing
perfectly fine you're going to get the
checks
if you're in over a certain amount even
if you're not doing this fine you're not
going to get it um so that's that's
that's poorly targeted certainly
and it's not unlike despite what the
media tries to tell us
um as always just like with zolensky's
green screen we're not supposed to
believe our lying eyes but it's not a
coincidence
it's not a coincidence
that for years they were giving out
these these
these
passing these massive spending bills
sending checks to everybody
pumping all this money into the system
and then you have inflation
that means it's exactly the thing
that um going back to the first coveted
relief bill
people like myself and many others were
saying this is going to cause inflation
and then what do you know you have
inflation
that's not a coincidence
um and no it's not we we can't put all
that on putin as much as we
might want to blame putin for everything
putin wasn't the one who sent out all
the checks to everybody i don't think
that was him
if he was then i think a lot of people
in america would like him a lot more
than they do
so that's what i'm trying to figure out
if the um
if the gas cards are poorly targeted
gonna cause inflation then how is a
stimulus check going to be better it
seems like that would be even worse
between the two options i think they're
both bad
but between the two options the gas
cover actually be better it would seem
because it'd be a little bit more
targeted
and and ensure that the money is
actually used on gas
as opposed to stimulus checklist be
wasted on anything you send like most
people you send them a stimulus check
they'll go out and buy a tv or something
that's just like that's
how a lot of people are wired
and here's the other thing that we that
you might take note of
to show how serious the government is
about bringing the gas prices down
um what about the the gas tax
you know um they're they're talking
about some efforts to can we give a
federal gas tax holiday
uh some states are talking about it as
well
but it hasn't happened yet
and why just a holiday i mean why not
get rid of these taxes
for the foreseeable future
but that's how serious they are of
course about about addressing this
problem
all right this is from the
new york post it says south carolina has
given the green light for condemned
prisoners in the state to be executed by
firing squad final approval came friday
after the state department of
corrections said renovations had been
completed
on a new death chamber where the
executions can take place in the state
capital of colombia
the electric chairs are the state's
primary method of execution but a may
2021 law now allows prisoners prisoners
to choose to die by lethal injection or
firing squad the state said in a press
release i'm just mentioning this because
this is you talk about common
i mean it's it's
it's crazy
that we've done away with the firing
squad
in so many of the states that still
allow um executions it's crazy we've
done away with executions in general in
many states but even the ones that allow
it getting rid of the firing shot like
what's what's the reason for that
well the reason is pretty simple it's
just it's just kind of like
trying to hide it's trying to sanitize
what what's happening
it's it's not about um
more humane methods of execution the
electric chair lethal injection
these certainly are not painless ways to
die
especially the electric chair
but
it sanitizes it a little bit and allows
you to hide a little bit from what's
happening which is that we're killing
someone
just justly rightfully
someone who this is the punishment that
they have warranted that they deserve
because of their actions
you know people who through their
monstrous actions have given society
really no choice but to deal with them
in this way
yet there's always this even it just
shows you something about our society
that even when it comes to how we
execute people i mean you're killing
them
and we still don't want to confront that
we're so afraid of death
and of confronting the reality of death
and confronting our own mortality that
even in executions we try to we try to
hide it
by putting someone on a
you know
strapping them down on a gurney and
injecting them with something and
we think that will somehow i don't know
what it what it's supposed to achieve
exactly
seems to me that firing squad is
obviously the cheapest way to go about
it the quickest way most the simplest
way
um
it also much much less opportunity for
things to go wrong when you hear about
cases of electric chair or lethal
injection
or that's administered to someone that's
the other thing we talk about
administering it right it's death we're
not killing someone we're just
administering it
but you hear of it being administered
and it goes wrong and then there's it
takes multiple attempts and
obviously it's agonizingly painful for
the person for the for the condemned
so not a lot of opportunity for it to go
wrong quick cheap and uh and also i
would think the most painless of all the
options
not a fun thing to experience but the
most painless
this is what this is what every state
should be and also you know rather than
dragging it out you know we we establish
that somebody is guilty of a horrific
crime and then 27 years later we bring
them in to
do the deed
how about we establish that they're
guilty they're convicted and i don't
know the next day you bring them out in
front of the firing squad
and that's
it
um
let's see
finally biggest and most important news
of the day that i have to mention um
on friday our very own candace owens
tweeted this she said one thing i would
like to understand is why dasani water
tastes so disgusting how is it possible
to make water taste this bad someone out
there knows the answer now
this caused
dasani water to trend nationwide on
twitter i mean it was trending for like
two days people were talking about
bottled water because of what candace
had tweeted which which is i mean you
know talk about driving the conversation
and it is an important conversation for
us to have i suppose uh and huge numbers
of people were agreeing
with candace that dasani water is bad
somehow
i didn't even i didn't know this was a
thing i didn't know that people
pretended to feel strongly
about what kind of bottled water they
prefer
especially as someone like if you can
find a a petty thing to feel weirdly
strong about
if it's possible to find it then i'm the
guy to find it
okay i spent 15 minutes ranting about
daylight savings time and how it's gonna
the senate bill making it permanent it's
gonna be the end of civilization so you
know i'm i can do that but even i
couldn't come up with a monologue on i
don't think i could do 15 minutes on
dasani water
yet all these people were saying how
dasani water's terrible talking about
what kinds of bottled water they
preferred and i responded calling
candace out you know i don't like to do
it
that often with my own colleagues but i
you know i i pointed out that all bottle
bottled water tastes the same and it all
tastes like tap water
all these bottled water companies
they're like getting the water it's just
from the same guy's kitchen sink that
they're all going in some guy lives in a
townhouse they all go in and just fill
their bottled water in that same sink it
all tastes exactly the same
um
and
she disagreed we went back and forth and
i finally threw the gauntlet down and i
said all
right um i'm challenging you to a blind
taste test
okay we put we put like four or five
cups of water
you tell me which is which
and so we are actually going to do that
she accepted the challenge and i mean i
just i bet 100 on it i put 100 bucks on
it
and i'm already thinking about all the
ways i'm going to spend my uh my
newfound wealth because there's i'm
sorry there is no way
unless they rigged this thing okay
unless this is another rigged election
there's no way
through a blind taste test you could
actually discern different types of
bottled water
i've already tested this out in fact i
got into an argument with my wife about
it because she was taking candace aside
it'd say oh yeah decided water is
disgusting so i said all right let's try
it so i went to the gas station i got i
got various different kinds of bottled
water and we tried the blind taste test
she failed she failed utterly so
i feel pretty confident
now let's get to our comment section
[Music]
um i don't know why i'm doing this but
let's play the video comment
hey sweet daddy walsh
i finally got you figured out
this explains why you're anti-social
you hate dogs
you're lazy and lie around on the couch
during holidays
and you like to fish especially at night
your cat
at least part cat
of course this won't explain your
tendency to wear skinny jeans but hey
anyway go ahead and cancel me
spg for life
thank you for that contribution to the
discussion um
well you know what i i you're not you're
not totally wrong because i do have a
cat and a dog and
to me it's
totally clear that cats are far superior
as as pets and that's just because
um
they're much more self-sufficient they
stay out of the way they can mostly take
care of themselves
and they're not begging they're not
desperate
for your attention and affection all the
time okay they're not they're not
begging you for attention
they're not they're not like emotionally
unstable like dogs so
i guess i won't take much issue with
that
let's see
byro says as someone with a useless art
degree i absolutely love matt's
leprechaun matt i highly encourage you
to illustrate your next best-selling
children's book perhaps it could be an
irish boy who identifies as a leprechaun
until he meets real leprechauns who
aren't so convinced by his professed
self-identity
you're welcome
i you know there are several comments
encouraging me in my artistic endeavors
and i think that it's mostly sarcastic
but it still it made me feel good and i
appreciate that um
cosmonaut says
if matt made an entire podcast reclining
back on his seat i'd watch it twice
it does give it a different sort of vibe
but the vibe is i don't care at all
about what i'm saying i don't know if
that's really what i should be
projecting branding wise
um
stacy says i love matty slightly more
offensive and slightly less
condescending than ben there's no way
ben is more condescending than me
actually ben isn't condescending at all
and i don't say this because he's my
boss but the guy's like a literal ivy
league genius and i'm a community
college dropout and i've never felt
condescended to by him
so i think that's that's just well there
was one time on the backstage debate
when we talked about aliens it was the
only time i felt condescended to by ben
and by everybody in the in the room
actually
and i still have not really recovered
from that
um
musical seizure guy
okay says uh quoting me our side waited
too long and then he says i really like
this channel but wish we didn't have
sides in this country like you have to
agree with everything a side says not
playing the blame game either i'm not
saying he started it oh well still
better than the view
yeah i guess it would be that would be
nice if there weren't if there weren't
sides if there wasn't a culture war
raging but
i mean there is there they're very clear
now
there's a very clear
dividing line in our culture and it's
not just a line it's actually it's like
a grand canyon okay it's a it's a vast
chasm
now when you on either side of that
chasm there are all kinds of different
factions and not everybody agrees and
that's where things get complicated
obviously we know on the so sort of on
the right side of that vast chasm
um
they're
it's we're not all getting along and we
don't all agree on a lot of the
fundamental issues
um but we are all on the same side of
that chasm at least
and what is that chasm exactly if i had
to kind of summarize it
um
i think it's the most fundamental thing
of all it's it's truth
you know you have one side that reject
they're they're relativists and they
reject that there is any actual truth at
all
there's no objective moral truth
um there's no and there's no objective
physical truth there's no objective
scientific truth
i think that if you had to summarize it
that's what it is
um and those are sides
i would like it if it wasn't that way
but it is
um and pretending otherwise and just
doing this oh well why can't we all get
along thing that that's not gonna help
um this is the world that we have
inherited
and the only way there's no there's no
bridging this divide okay there's no
there's no compromise like there's no
compromise position between there's no
truth and there is truth
um there's no compromise position
between we shouldn't kill babies we
should kill babies
no compromise position between
um women have penises they don't right
like there's no there's no compromise
there no compromise between uh we should
sexualize children at six years old and
teach them about sexuality and gender
identity and we shouldn't there's no
compromise position between that
so
ultimately
if the two sides are kind of if if that
if that divide if that canyon is filled
if there is no divide anymore it's going
to be because one side has emerged
victorious over the other it's not
because they all got along somewhere in
the middle the middle doesn't exist
it's because one side won
and again you might not like to see it
that way but that's that's how it is
and we should probably face it you guys
know we don't stop making great content
here at the daily wire and we're super
excited then about our latest
docu-series fauci unmasked the show
exposes the most successful failure in
government history dr anthony fauci
hosted by our very own knuckle michael
knowles he peels back the mask on
fauchi's past and shows the world's
leading scientist for what he really is
which is a fraud all three episodes
dropped last week and it's seriously
good you can watch the entire thing now
binge it all in one sitting uh check out
the sneak peek here
he's the highest paid employee in our
federal government and beginning in the
spring of 2020 dr fauci began to set
national policy that affected the way
that 330 million americans lived their
lives for goodness sakes i'm telling you
wear a mask keep social distancing
there's nothing political about that but
who is anthony fauci people who have
conspiracy theories those are people
that don't particularly care for me in
this short series
we will do what the establishment media
have refused to do
we will give you an unvarnished look at
the career of the most powerful
politician in america
dr anthony thatcher don't you think it's
time that you step down and let someone
else who has a more effective message
actually no
the last part of the three-part series
is streaming now and is available
exclusively to daily wire so if you're
not a member yet head to dailywire.com
subscribe to join today the show is
excellent and since we're only adding
more content every day you don't want to
miss this now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
well as you probably recall last week we
discussed the work being done by senator
josh hawley to expose some of the
troubling facts about scotus nominee
contanji brown jackson's record her her
actual judicial record that is not the
sort of record that you know democrats
focus on when it comes to republican
nominees famously scrounging up their
high school yearbooks and demanding to
know how many parties they went to in
high school
that's the democrat approach to judicial
vetting at least when the nominee is
selected by the other party in this case
you know we have no idea whether
kantanji jackson partied in high school
or wrote vulgarities on her yearbook no
one's asking that question what we do
know however is that she has a
long-standing and quite nasty habit of
going easy on child sex predators as a
judge to refresh your memory here's the
daily wires report from last week so
senator josh holly said wednesday that
president joe biden's supreme court
nominee has a pattern of letting child
porn offenders off the hook for their
appalling crimes i've been researching
the record of judge kantanji brown
jackson reading her opinions articles
interviews and speeches i've noticed an
alarming pattern when it comes to judge
jackson's treatment of sex offenders
especially those preying on children
holly claimed that as far back as during
jackson's time in law school the judge
has questioned whether convicts should
be made to register sex offenders and
said that it leads to stigmatization and
ostracism she suggested public policy is
driven by a climate of fear hatred and
revenge against sex offenders and it
gets worse holly warned as a member of
the u.s sentencing commission judge
jackson advocated for drastic changes in
how the law treats sex offenders by
eliminating the existing mandatory
minimum sentences for child porn
now he goes into extensive deep detail
providing citations and documentation
along the way
um here's a little bit more from the
daily wire it says the missouri
republican further said that jackson has
suggested there may be a type of less
serious child pornography offender whose
motivation is not sexual and noted that
during jackson's time in the u.s
sentencing commission jackson said she
mistakenly assumed that child
pornography offenders are pedophiles
jackson also said that she wanted to
understand this category of
non-pedophiles who obtained child
pornography
on the federal bench judd jackson put
her troubling views into action he
tweeted in every single child porn case
for which she can find we could find
records judge jackson deviated from the
federal sentencing guidelines in favor
of child porn offenders
okay now this all sounds quite damning
but don't worry the media assures us
that holly's claims have been debunked
here's a george schnephilopogus on abc
explaining
we are seeing escalating attacks from
some senate republicans like josh hawley
who set out a twitter
series of tweets suggesting that judge
jackson is somehow soft on child porn
it's been debunked by several
independent fact checkers but what does
that tell you about the confirmation
fight ahead
well i'm not sure what it signals but as
far as senator hawley is concerned
here's the bottom line he's wrong he's
inaccurate and unfair in his analysis
judge jackson has been scrutinized more
than any person i can think of
now you notice as always that the people
claiming that the claims have been
debunked never actually explain how they
were debunked they never tell you what
the debunking proved only that the
debunking occurred
and we can just rest assured that
there's nothing at all to see here it
was debunked and that's it
i guess the msnbc took it a step further
insisting that the scrutiny of judge
jackson is all really a plot to get her
killed listen
i need the democrats to get up there and
defend her just as vociferously
as lindsey graham defended alleged
attempted rapist brett kavanaugh like i
need that level of energy for the
democrats especially when they come at
her with this with this trumped up um uh
alleged issues about uh her sentencing
on uh for sex offenders um because what
josh hawley is doing let's let's be very
clear what josh hawley is doing when he
tries to do this um is he's trying to
get her kill
he is trying to get violence done
against a supreme court nominee
of course when holly mentions jackson's
judicial record he's trying to get her
killed
but would democrats accuse a republican
nominee of being the ringleader of a
roving gang of serial rapists
that's just fair play
now these same people said that amy
coney barrett is the member of a secret
sinister handmaid's cult
um turns out she's just catholic by the
way but
that was all legitimate yet the
slightest scrutiny on jackson is not
only false debunked misinformation but
also offensive outrageous racist a call
for violence
this is the level of discourse in this
country of course
now the left's actual response to the
charges made against jackson if they're
being honest
if they're being honest about it would
be that they actually agree with her
that child porn is not a very serious
crime of course for all their moral
handwringing about kavanaugh uh you know
they wouldn't actually give a damn if
jackson was a serial killer herself you
know they wouldn't care if she if she
liked to burn down orphanages in her
spare time they just want to get her on
the bench so even if they normally
objected child pornography they still
wouldn't let that get in the way of
their support for jackson as a nominee
obviously
but as it happens they actually they
actually do agree with her lenient
approach to the crime
as their efforts at debunking have shown
here's the here's the abc fact check
which makes this point clear this is
supposed to be this is you know we heard
snuffleupagus on abc saying this has
been debunked well here's abc's
debunking
and here's what they say
while court records show that jackson
did impose lighter sentences than
federal guidelines suggested holly's
insinuation neglects critical context
including the fact that the senator
himself has voted to confirm at least
three federal judges who also engaged in
the same practice
quote if and when we properly
contextualize judge jackson's sentencing
record in federal child porn cases it
looks pretty mainstream according to
doug berman a leading expert on
sentencing law and policy at the ohio
state university school of law
federal judges nationwide typically
sentenced below the child porn
guidelines in roughly two out of three
cases and when deciding to go below the
child porn guideline typically impose
sentences around 54 months below the
calculated guideline minimum
judge jax's record in these child porn
cases does show she is quite skeptical
of the range set by the child porn
guidelines but so too were prosecutors
in the majority for cases and so too are
district judges nationwide appointed by
presidents of both parties
okay so that's the debunking
the first point in this fact check just
paints holly as a hypocrite on this
issue which maybe he is or maybe he
isn't that has nothing to do with
whether the claims themselves are true
the rest just assures us that jackson's
approach is mainstream and lots of other
judges do it and it's totally fine and
normal and good in other words says the
fact checker i personally agree with her
on the issue and so i don't see it as a
big deal
that doesn't debunk the claim about made
about jackson it confirms it they
confirm it in the first sentence
saying she's leaning on child porn
offenders
that that's what that's what holly said
so it's confirmed
confirmed fact
now if i accuse you of doing something
and you say yeah i did it but uh you
know everyone else is doing it too
you haven't debunked my accusation you
can't say i did it but everyone's doing
it see you're debunked
no you've verified my accusation
you've admitted to it
the rest whether it's true that everyone
else is doing it whether it's good that
everyone is doing it if they are in fact
doing all of that is beside the
immediate point the immediate point is
that what i said about you is true
and that's what these media fact
checkers have done with the accusations
against jackson
now is it true that lots of judges are
lenient on child sex predators sure
lots of judges are lenient on many
crimes especially sex crimes
that's why there are so many violent
perverts walking the street as we speak
is it good to be lenient though is it
justified no absolutely not
jackson's soft pedaling approach extends
beyond child porn it goes to sex
predators who engage in physical abuse
as well but even just when it comes to
child porn these are people whether
distributors or consumers who are
participating in the most debased and
vile form of exploitation imaginable
what they've done deserves the severest
punishments available to us by law and
even some punishments not available to
us
also
these people are are dangerous to the
public and will always be a danger
even if it's theoretically possible to
rehabilitate some of them which i'm
skeptical of
even then it's it's certainly not
possible to ever be very confident in
their rehabilitation they will always
represent a threat no parent would ever
feel safe living next to a guy who was
previously convicted on child porn
charges
that's why they should be locked in
prison for as long as possible it's the
safest thing it's also justice
which is something that a justice of the
supreme court should know something
about
but jackson doesn't and that's why judge
jackson and all the fake debunkers
coming to her aid are today cancelled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavovsky our
associate producer is mckenna waters the
show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike cormina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
22.
john bickley here daily wire
editor-in-chief wake up every morning
with our show morning wire where we
bring you all the news that you need to
know in 15 minutes or less join me and
my co-host georgia hal for daily
coverage of all the biggest stories on
morning wire